now the US president has announced new
guidelines to limit the spread of the
virus including limiting the social
gatherings to less than 10 people Donald
Trump says he's not currently
considering a nationwide curfew but one
could be imposed in certain hotspots my
administration is recommending that all
Americans including the young and
healthy work to engage in schooling from
home when possible avoid gathering in
groups of more than 10 people avoid
discretionary travel and avoid eating
and drinking at bars restaurants and
public food courts if everyone makes
this change or these critical changes
and sacrifices now we will rally
together as one nation and we will
defeat the virus and we're going to have
a big celebration all together dr. Alan
Fisher who's in Washington DC so a
tightening of the measures but not
perhaps as far as other countries are
going well he was asked specifically are
you considering a national quarantine
and he said no but they may look at some
hotspots it's interesting that at the
man who is leading the medical response
to the corona virus here in the United
States so some people may say is this
too inconvenient to introduce these
restrictions for 15 days have we gone
too far the answer is no we have not
because if you think you're ahead of
where you are you're not you're actually
always just slightly behind which
slightly contradicts what Donald Trump
said earlier later in that statement
when he said we're ahead of the curve
just in the last few minutes I've been
listening to the rest of the briefing
which is still going on he was asked how
would you read how the United States
government how your administration has
responded to this out of ten and he gave
himself a ten they're hoping that these
restrictions will stop people
transmitting the virus because we saw it
the weekend pictures from across the
United States of busy bars and clubs it
is the time when a lot of colleges and
universities here in the United States
have spring break and so people head off
and they party and they enjoy themselves
but they are trying to stop that
so I'm going to and Alan the the economy
is the big fear I suppose there was a
kind of a mention of the recession word
but but President Trump was reluctant to
use it wasn't he no one in the
administration wants to see that part of
that's political because Donald Trump is
beating his reelection on the strength
of the economy and there is no doubt
that has taken a head
they are looking perhaps specific
measures to help the airline industry
and they talked about that there is also
the possibility to that the the bill
that was passed by the house on Friday
will be amended by the Senate know that
they have got their hands that know
they're back after the weekend one of
the measures being considered has been
put forward by Mitt Romney a Republican
senator you may remember him that he ran
for president several years ago he is
suggesting that perhaps there should be
a one thousand dollar payment made to
every American to try and boost the
economy the central bank did what they
thought was right on Sunday by cutting
interest rates to almost zero and also
introducing elements of quantitative
easing the most dramatic intervention in
the American financial market since the
2008 financial crisis but that did not
reflect well in the markets just before
they closed the the stock market was
down about three thousand points which
is a very very significant drop Donald
Trump says it will come roaring back
when they finally start to get things
back to normal but asked when that would
be he says that perhaps this may start
to wash through in some time in July or
August Allen Fisher thank you very much
indeed